[Music]
there's no shortage of aliens in sci-fi
Fantastical beings from Distant Worlds
have been a staple of the genre since
its conception yet while entertaining
not all pop culture aliens are the most
scientifically rigorous but the yetawan
sagas a vast new speculative Evolution
project from talented artists Christian
Klein explores its titular species with
breathtaking detail with over 200 Pages
dedicated to the yedawan's epic journey
from microbes to the Stars the book
might be the densest exploration of a
single alien species ever written so for
this entry into the archive we'll
attempt to Fathom the sheer complexity
of the yadawans With a Little Help from
the author himself and like my videos on
Klein's other series The teeming
Universe you can purchase the book using
the links below
Our Story begins around 3 billion years
ago with a planet called yetu slightly
larger than Earth it is a world perfect
for the emergence of life on the
planet's surface the first single-celled
organisms are just beginning to develop
around hydrothermal vents deep in the
heart of the ocean for the next several
billion years life will Wax and Wane
growing and shrinking in accordance with
mass extinctions As Time spirals onwards
through different eras compared to
Earth's history life takes its time
getting onto land but eventually
surface-dwelling species emerge
breathing in the crisp air and now a new
chapter in the story of Life can begin
eight million years ago a hum fills the
hazy morning air as thousands of flying
organisms take off from a dense forest
canopy this ancient rainforest is as
large as the continental United States
and within its impenetrable branches a
vast multitude of species Thrive
including one with the destiny and the
stars in the understory of the forest
the early proto-yetawans cling to the
side of great fungal shells with their
six clawed limbs these tree-dwelling
social omnivores are just one of many
related species at the time content to
hold a minor Niche within a larger
ecosystem the H1 Forest biosphere
overflows with abundance plants fungi
and strange composite organisms called
plungi keep the ecosystem in stable
Harmony but this idyllic environment
will soon change forever over the next
several million years tectonic
collisions and volcanic activity into
over Drive the resultant rapid warming
transforming the rainforest into a
sparse desert tens of thousands of
species the proto-yetuans included are
left without a home yet this will not be
the end of the proto-yatt ones but the
beginning forced to adapt the species
evolves to live on the ground and take
shelter in caves becoming more
resourceful and more intelligent
eventually the proto-yetuans evolve into
true yetu ones the central species of
The Saga the fundamental yetuan body
plan is something Klein spent extra time
developing and is based on real science
what I had in mind for Diego ones was
what is a good example of traits which
astrobiologists attribute to an
intelligent species like they would have
a head with a larger brain they would
have hands to like manipulate stuff all
aspects of y81 anatomy from their
skeleton to their internal organs to
their nervous system or mapped out with
an astonishing amount of detail their
skulls are Hefty to accommodate an
expanded Cranium and their beaks are
actually derived from their two front
teeth a structure which acts as a
powerful natural weapon 850
000 years ago prehistoric yetuan Hunters
the indigo people surveyed The Horizon
from a high Vantage Point overlooking a
mighty Lake an early nomadic Society the
Indigo Traverse vast distances in search
of game and have learned to wear face
paint from animal fat in fine clay to
protect themselves from the bright Sun
with the Advent of these early tool
users the planet will never ever be the
same early yetuan tools reflect their
unique Anatomy with their Stone
spearheads designed to augment the
pre-existing biting power of their beaks
the Antigo people also craft spear
throwers to Aid their short arms in
launching projectiles in containers to
transport materials the Antigo persists
for over 400 000 years even learning to
domesticate some wild species in a
limited capacity local platoderms serve
as occasional hunting companions yet the
Indigo and their helpers would soon
vanish
but other yadawin groups soon arise in
the anticipative Rays of the Rising Sun
The hulele People proudly Overlook the
fertile Valley they call home perhaps
the first sedentary Farmers these early
yadawin agriculturalists are likely
responsible for The Disappearance of the
Indigo who couldn't compete with this
new way of life yet as will often be the
case in yato in history the conclusion
of one chapter is just the start of
another the hulali domesticate numerous
species for food and Medicine which they
honor in small Sandstone Effigies most
cultures of this period are lost to the
ages with only Stone artifacts surviving
the Long March of time over the next
several hundred thousand years various
groups fan out across the continent
prehistoric societies come and go like
the seasons struggling to find a
foothold but in time complex
civilization is born on the banks of the
cestis river some 30 years ago colossal
stone structures Tower over a sprawling
Bronze Age City this is the erio
civilization an Empire of a size and
strength the planet has never seen
before a new system of farming plants
and plungy allows the eriu to flourish
through artificial irrigation and
fertilization the Empire produces enough
food to sustain its considerable
population for centuries life on the
edge of the cestus river is a paradise
with yaduin's hurting livestock and
enjoying an abundance of food and though
eventually this Empire will disappear as
the River dries up and forming becomes
unsustainable the iriyu will live on
through their impact on future
civilizations
long after the fall Torchlight flickers
in the windows of modest dwellings a
thousand years have passed since the uru
collapsed and from the fragments of the
Old Kingdom the ergle Empire has formed
as evidenced by the great domed palace
shining on the horizon the ergle people
proved to be great Navigators creating
Maps more accurate than any that came
before in time they even chart the
planet's Eastern land mass the first
yachuins to have done so utta is the
name of the New Kingdom the urgal empire
establishes in the East composed of
city-states with the unique culture in a
deep connection to the ocean and as the
urgal civilization begins to decline
utta feels less and less obligation to
the waning Empire across the sea
chattering voices fill the air as a
merchant makes their way through a
bustling Marketplace on the outskirts of
the uttan Empire now officially
separated from erga which collapsed due
to being stretched too thin utta is free
to forge their own destiny in a rapidly
changing World uttan culture is vibrant
and distinct lavish bath houses adorned
with extravagant sculptures and stylized
murals or common sight in the heart of
the Empire a reflection of a society
that values art and creativity all
aspects of yatoan societies are
carefully conceptualized with Klein
considering how different environments
might produce different civilizations
how would geography play into their
cultures how would that affect our
writing how that affect their world view
how they affect their art how do they
engage in war one year to win living in
the utan culture is an artisan named
Kenny working in a coastal Studio some
000 years ago a fragment of her diary
offers a brief personal look into uttan
daily life Kenny crafts high-end pottery
from White Clay adorning the sides with
depictions of oceanic life in particular
the vexus qualians the closest analog to
fish on the yatun Homeworld the numerous
species of vexus qualians are
indispensable to the coastal Utah but
while Utah thrives on the other side of
the water the Ergo Empire is collapsing
further due to mismanagement in a
fast-spreading disease wall paintings
from this era warn locals of the lethal
illness personifying the infection as a
god of death in dread almost
simultaneously with this wave of disease
a far greater cataclysm befalls the
planet the tutu Neu super volcano
explodes in the immediate Inferno long
volcanic winter that follows all but
extinguishes erga in innumerable other
cultures even utta across the sea is
reduced to a shadow of its former self a
grim silence descends over the world in
the ages that follow trade between the
Western and Eastern hemispheres halts
almost completely with the two regions
losing contact with each other for over
a thousand years yet this Darkness
cannot last forever the Ada ones of the
East and West continue to progress
independently in a post-eruption world
in time the disparate halves of the
eduen people ReDiscover each other in a
new era of exploration the exchange of
knowledge leading to technological
innovations
industrialization at last comes to yetu
and with it a new world of possibilities
and dangers open up for while some
emerging inventions are cause for
celebration others are cause for alarm
new forms of gun unpatter fueled
weaponry and kinetic bombs make Warfare
more destructive than ever before short
yet vicious skirmishes called flash Wars
break out between leading Powers
conflicts that exist in between longer
periods of Cold standoffs Yet following
the flash War period a post-war boom
allows industrialization to spread
quickly as Society changes a cultural
emphasis on grooming develops with
advertisements encouraging yetuans to
scrub their beaks using beak paste more
complex Feats of engineering become
possible with vast Bridges creating new
points of connection between land masses
across the planet co-dependence between
nations grows increasingly common living
in this time of ceasefire and Innovation
is arcter an older yetuan engineer whose
personal records give us another glimpse
of daily life Archer lives in the
countryside of a large industrial nation
working as a vehicle schematics
contractor he spends much of his time at
his station coming up with new methods
of transportation including a new type
of flying machine that can travel long
distances but this era of peace and
progress can't endure eternally for
another technology is right around the
corner one so fundamental its Discovery
is only a matter of time a yetuan
scientist finds a way to split the atom
into nuclear arms race begins once the
world is armed only one mistake is
needed a small political leader
detonates their nuclear weapon in an act
of desperation beginning a chain
reaction of retaliation that ends in
global nuclear war the outcome is
apocalyptic life is a very fragile thing
and with thousands and tens of thousands
of years go by it's like that's
basically almost a guarantee that
something cataclysmic will happen and
like life will be on The Fringe decades
after the last bomb Falls a scavenger
picks through the skeletal remains of a
city for supplies tens of millions of
yetuans died in the initial blasts and
subsequent Fallout with scars running
deep in their cultural memory long after
the dust settled but as long as pockets
of survivors continued to endure the
world is not truly lost for a long
period Nations kept to themselves doing
their best to rebuild with what they
have yet eventually new alliances form
humbled by past experiences and under
enormous public pressure dozens of
leaders form a multinational Coalition
known as the world Alliance after a long
period of healing a yetuan Explorer
takes their first step on the planet's
closest Moon the one small step for a
year to win this moment represents a
giant leap forward for the species as a
whole after so many decades of hardship
and Recovery the stars are now reachable
and the Uncharted void of space Echoes
with the promise of Discovery centuries
later the yetuans make the
interplanetary leap bravely launching a
ship containing 62 passengers towards
yaided the planet closest to the yadawin
Homeworld the astronauts on board the
vessel are not just explorers but
permanent settlers in the early days of
the settlement life on yaided is Harsh
and exacting but with each subsequent
Generation The Colony becomes more
sustainable and more livable soon a new
sense of planetary identity forms
distinct from that of yetu back home
yeduan civilization is much changed with
the vast majority of people living in
bright sprawling metropolises yet this
new age is not without its problems
climatological shifts brought on by
global pollution causes many regions of
the world to steadily destabilize
despite advances in technology and
Medicine sin in the years to come food
shortages reach a point of crisis in the
largest mega cities interrential acid
rain poses an almost ever-present threat
in the face of never-ending
environmental hazards most yada winds
have no choice but to spend the majority
of their life indoors in the large
cities where conditions are cramped
standards of living go into free fall in
the face of such unpleasant lives
hundreds of millions of volunteers sign
up to work in the Terran asteroid belt
in a program designed to create new
supply lines to Aid the resource
depleted Homeworld the asteroid Force
proves to be a success kindling hope for
the yetuan's future in an orbit above
yetu another project is underway the
first of the Titanic engine ships is
under construction several mile long
vessels that will go further than any
before although completion is centuries
off the project gives the yadawans a
dream to strive towards back on the
ground all hands are on Deck to try and
mitigate and reverse the environmental
destruction of the yetuin home planet in
the era to come scientists build
towering structures known as
sequestration Towers to remove
pollutants from the atmosphere in the
asteroid belt permanent farming
satellites improve life for both
yedawins living in the belt colonies and
the millions of starving citizens on the
Homeworld trade between yetu and
extraplanetary colonies has never been
stronger but life for the average a to
end living in an urban area can still be
difficult which the personal log of a
young City dweller named ilso helps
illuminate growing up in a polluted
region ilso is drafted to take part in
an exploratory program that will take
her far from home for the Titanic engine
ships are at last nearing completion
these gargantuan vessels will be sent to
distance systems in an attempt to
continue the yeto one species in case
the Homeworld restoration project fails
they'll carry with them the precious
cargo of millions of yadu ones in
suspended animation who will be the
first settlers of these new worlds ilso
is one such settler like all yadawan
Saga characters she's just an ordinary
citizen in a wide universe a trend that
was quite intentional one thing that I
really wanted to emphasize and like kind
of subvert was the idea of characters
and like who are they they're not Heroes
they're not these kind of mythical
Herculean brave soldiers who are one of
a kind like they're lay people they're
average
the Titanic engines rocket out into the
void moving it faster than light speeds
thanks to new engines that warp
space-time in just a few short years
these ships will transport their
passengers further than any yada one has
gone before one Titanic engine heads to
agda an earth-sized Planet located eight
light years away from yetu all
preliminary studies suggest the world
would be ideal for establishing a
settlement on it isn't long after a
permanent settlement is established that
disaster strikes in a perfect storm of
tragic circumstances the solar flare
from the nearby star destroys the
colony's power supply a panicked
engineer hurries to send a distress
signal but this cry will go unanswered
due to the vast distances between
systems several Millennia passed before
any ship travels to agda to check on the
settlement having grown used to long
periods of Silence from settlements
beyond the home system the response team
has no idea what awaits them as they
break atmosphere the surface seems
Barren and deserted the power seemingly
completely shut down this is not a
planet of the living to the horror of
the reconnaissance Team all members of
the AG dissettlement have long since
perished unable to survive on an
unterraformed Planet without power it is
the tragedy that the yadawans will never
forget
returning to yetu the planet has now
recovered almost completely from
climatological disaster thanks to
sequestration towers built within cities
and more citizens living in sustainable
arcologies the yedawans can breathe air
freely once again in the wake of agda's
catastrophe the settling of new worlds
soon ceases once and for all with the
etawans collectively deciding to instead
focus on bettering the regions of space
they've already claimed a new era of
prosperity and Enlightenment begins with
the yadawans reaching New Heights both
technologically and academically
at last we've reached the present era in
the great journey of yetuan History if
the tale is not yet complete for in the
modern era numerous fascinating cultures
have emerged scattered across multiple
planets each with their own stories
Planet deity is an exoplanet located 12
light years from yetu a terraformed
jewel in the crown of yedawan
settlements the world is famed for its
stunning canyons and waterfalls dayetti
is also known for its unique culinary
Traditions born of limitations and what
early settlers could carry with them on
their ships today it is a bustling
vibrant World steeped in culture in the
smells of local cuisine on the other
side of the sector planet kecadi is a
larger and more densely populated World
a technologically oriented Planet one
might expect to find it lacking in
Tradition yet on the contrary kekady is
home to numerous traditional rituals
including a form of dance that tells the
tale of the world's struggles and
triumphs Planet odd is a more recent
settlement that is yet to be terraformed
yet the planet has a megalithic
structure that makes it one of a kind a
colossal space elevator so vast it can
be seen from distant orbit transports
materials from the Stars down to the
surface and vice versa it is the
lifeblood of Planet Odd as a result the
citizens of odd are fiercely protective
of the structure armored guards Patrol
the base of the elevator constantly
their lives dedicated to keeping the
settlement that has emerged around the
central cable safe and orderly even
Planet agda once the site of the great
solar flare disaster has been
transformed into a thriving settlement a
distinct form of religion has emerged on
the surface which venerates the original
settlers who died in the initial flare
long ago followers of this discipline
are associated with the symbol of a
golden sun with seven solar rays it is
just one example of how complex and
distinct yedawan culture has become
spread out through the Stars returning
to yetu a final time the citizens of the
Homeworld strive to remember those who
have come before with new efforts in
archeology unearthing more stories from
yetu's past yedemon history is an uneven
road but in learning from the mistakes
of their ancestors yedawans May Forge a
better future
across sci-fi The yedawan Saga stands
out due to the sheer complexity of the
book's lore which combines speculative
history and science in innovative ways I
wanted the yellow and sagas to be an
example of how specular biology can
interplay with speculative culture and
how it can be cool the yada ones are a
Triumph of alien World building with so
much detail across the many pages that
there's still a lot of content that
didn't make it into this video it's a
rare Delight to see a speculative
Evolution project in book format
something the author hopes will become
more popular I encourage the spec Evo
Community to Branch out into the print
medium because it's something that's
very uncommon in the sub-genre if you
find the yedawan sagas as interesting as
I do you can purchase the book using the
links below to get the full story and
follow Christian Klein on social media
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
foreign
foreign thank you